what's going on guys this is rob and we
have explained classic loki we've
explained lady loki and so in this video
we're going to explain
kid loki now kid loki is a really cool
concept and it's kind of a benefit or
sort of a
in addition to this we'll actually sort
of bookend into the origin of ikol which
is basically loki spelled backwards just
because the origin of these characters
sort of go hand in hand but for those of
you guys who have been a part of my
channel for a long long time we're gonna
kick things off by talking about siege
on asgard so that's not gonna be new to
you especially if you've read the comic
or you've seen my videos on siege on
asgard but the important thing here is
that
loki in the events of siege on asgard
had already returned as lady loki
basically when when ragnarok happened
and asgard was destroyed
loki's soul took over the body that was
meant for sif and so loki came back as a
chick basically
had some cool stories it was pretty
interesting but loki's overall
philosophy was that the asgardians
didn't have
any business residing on earth for a
couple different reasons
one because he saw that in the cosmic
order of
beings as they exist throughout the
whole universe that as guardians were
beyond humanity right that there was no
reason for humanity to associate with
the asgardians on that level
and so just by that kind of metaphorical
belief system loki wanted asgard
the actual castle land whatever you want
to call it to return to its home
dimension which is
also called asgard and to sort of
operate from there the other part of
that
is that loki believed because asgardians
were beyond humans
physically they don't need to be in the
same place right and so what he sought
to do was basically orchestrate a series
of circumstances where the asgardians
would come to the realization that earth
didn't want them and so loki allied
himself with norman osborn who at that
point had taken over as director of
shield and then you got the siege on
asgard event the biggest issue that
happened with that is loki's plan
backfired completely instead what ended
up happening is the void who's kind of
like this evil
alternate persona of the superhero of
the century ended up taking over the
century's body
and then killed loki in the process and
trashed all of asgard and so when that
happened
loki effectively died now from there of
course you go into the conclusion of c
don't asgard the voids defeated and all
that kind of stuff and so on and so
forth but one of the big takeaways from
this is you go
into uh really thor by matt fraction
which kind of kicks off
with issue 617 going forward and what
you end up finding out is that classic
loki knew that he was eventually going
to die
for real specifically there was a strong
possibility with the plan he was going
for
to get asgard back to its home dimension
and so in order to ensure that if he did
die that he would be able to come back
he ended up sort of making a deal with
hella who you guys know
basically runs the the realm of hell
kind of the afterlife or as guardians or
at least those who don't die in
honorable battle
those guys actually go to valhalla but
for the average age guardian somebody
like like loki who's really spent most
of his existence being a dick
uh he was going to go to the realm of
hell in order to ensure that didn't
happen
what loki did is he made a deal to have
his name removed from the books of hella
now the books of hella are kind of
is basically like this ledger that keeps
track of all the people who are
essentially going to die
and that when their time comes if they
don't go to valhalla they go to her
realm loki having his name removed from
that kind of granted him a sort of
temporary immortality and i say
temporary because in marvel comics
immortality is kind of a wonky thing
let's talk about this for a second
a lot of people confuse immortality and
marvel comics with invulnerability in
marvel comics immortality and
invulnerability
are not mutually exclusive they're not
the same thing the reality here is a
person who is genuinely immortal
is basically a being who will never die
of old age and they'll never die of
disease
they can be killed in other ways right
you can cut the head off a person who's
immortal and then separate their head
from their body and as long as they stay
separated
that person will die there's only a
couple exceptions to that deadpool when
he was cursed with immortality
by thanos deadpool basically his healing
factor is what kept him immortal in that
capacity
during the funeral for a freak storyline
when deadpool grew back from a hand
different things like that
thanos is actually banned from the realm
of mistress death so he can never really
die he'll just stay alive forever and
ever and ever
even when he died during the events of
like jonathan hickman's avengers and new
avengers uh in the the secret wars event
that that thanos actually ended up in
the realm of what was called oblivion he
was basically
outside the multiverse in a realm of
nothingness because he was immortal
there was nowhere for him to go
[Laughter]
so he just kind of ended up there
invulnerability means you cannot be
defeated or you cannot be
physically harmed so long as the power
of the person you're fighting does not
supersede your level of invulnerability
so somebody like loki could be killed
easily by somebody like thanos
because loki is invulnerable but he's
not invulnerable relative to thanos he's
invulnerable relative to like iron man
or somebody like that right you know
somebody relatively weak
so again there's huge differences there
but immortality is a little bit of a
wonky thing in this instance loki had it
in a temporary capacity his name was
removed from the books
once but it can never stay that way
right like if an event comes along where
he will die his name will be put back in
the books again and then he'll go to the
realm of hella and he'll remain there
presumably until the end of the universe
and everything is reborn again but the
important thing about this
is because his name was removed when he
died during the events of siege on
asgard during thor issue number 617
he was reborn in paris the kicker to
this is he was reborn with a clean slate
he had no idea about his own past and he
didn't have any of his magical energy
instead it was just loki reborn and
human form now thor eventually figured
out what was going on he basically
located loki and then brought him back
to asgard now by that point in time odin
was already back and a lot of the
stories when you looked at like thor's
617 running all the way up to 619 under
matt fraction
a lot of what was going on with loki was
largely background stuff and the biggest
issue that you had going on with this
character was just kind of this desire
to
show everybody that he's not that he
wasn't the same villain that he used to
be right he wasn't the same the
the kind of mischievous guy who would do
some terrible things that would kind of
you know
cause problems and havoc or that he
would initiate asgard because that was
kind of the big thing that was being
held over his head
during those stories was you're the the
you're the loki that initiated asgard
you're the loki that basically got all
of us
killed right like that was the big
depiction that was shown with this
character and so he was constantly
wrestling against that
it was cool because it was interesting
to see how a reborn version of loki
who's basically an innocent kid that
doesn't know anything about his past
being told you're the reason why we're
all dead and having that responsibility
held against him and it wasn't just the
asgardians who were doing it it was odin
as well odin didn't like him he did not
like loki at all you did see a few
moments when odin basically said okay
like i mean i still see him as my son
even if i don't like him and i would
never actually allow
any harm to come to him but in a lot of
ways it was only ever really thor who
was looking out for him and thor who was
vouching for him and trying to get
asgardians to trust him now
following that what you ended up getting
was kid loki kind of going off
into his own individual story but the
launch of his individual story actually
came
with journey into mystery and it was one
that really focused on the origin or the
creation of the character of
ikel and so the way this played out is
you ended up having kid loki who was
sort of lured to this kind of cave right
this kind of location where he ended up
meeting this sort of spiritual specter
of his former self and what he ended up
telling him was that somewhere along the
line
loki at least classic loki will return
right classic loki is going to have to
find a way to come back because there's
going to be all kinds of terrors and
threats that are going to face off
against
asgard and going to challenge everything
that asgard stands for and that he's
going to need
you know the the power that classic loki
has now of course we ended up
discovering that what classic loki was
referring to this kind of
chaotic craziness and trials and
tribulations that that were going to go
on in asgard was largely the events of
fear
itself but this basically led to kid
loki kind of assisting the return of
classic loki but only in so far that he
was sort of
transformed into a somewhat younger and
teenage version of himself that was
called
aikol now the launch of journey into
mystery featuring ikol
and kid loki was pretty significant for
a couple different reasons because a lot
of the matt fraction work on
on kid loki again was focused on this
kind of redemption right kid loki always
trying to show the asgardians that he
was a good guy
and this happened in multiple ways when
kid loki had helped him defeat galactus
by hiding the world see different things
along those lines but probably his
greatest achievement in terms of
demonstrating the fact that he was
really on the
on the side of the asgardians came
during fear itself now understand fear
itself
deals a lot with a being called the
serpent who is basically the secret
brother
of odin that nobody ever really knew
about and that he was supposedly
supposed to be the rightful heir to
asgard and odin had actually stolen that
from him and so
when he arose a few things happened
right you saw him creating all these
different hammers they were kind of like
these variants of mjolnir and then they
were given to these wildly powerful
people so for example juggernaut
received a hammer and then went forward
as an agent of the serpent
eventually the serpent himself rose to
power now for kid loki and ikel the cool
thing about this is a lot of their
actions were a background plot that came
to fruition in the conclusion
and actually helped to save the day and
what you ended up learning was a few
different things that the overall
gist of what it was that the kid loki
had done was to work alongside mephisto
and hella to basically have them team up
defend their realms and then basically
capture
or at least attain something called the
hell wolf which would allow him to ride
into limbo
and then meet with certain where sorter
had essentially been since the events of
the 1990s and really even
during ragnarok when he had essentially
been defeated at the end of all things
and so the deal that was made by loki
and ikol was that serder
if he would give them a piece of his
twilight sword which is basically this
gigantic sword that has a myriad of
different powers that if he would give
them a piece of it they would in turn
let him destroy asgard and so when the
serpent rose to power the serpent
created what was called dark asgard
which is kind of like a dark and twisted
version of asgard as it existed the
intention
to build his own army and then invade
asgard proper
destroy it and then rule it himself
right to kill kill off owning all those
guys with i cole
and kid loki working together they use
their their fraction of the twilight
sword to kind of
rewrite the history of the serpent to
basically make it easier for thor to
defeat him which of course cost the life
of thor
and the pack that was agreed upon
between ikol and kid loki basically
allowed
certain to enter into the mortal realm
and and wipe out asgard the difference
was he was wiping out
dark asgard right so kind of cleaning up
everything that had to do with the
serpent and asgard itself continued on
but that right there had solidified
everything that had gone on with kid
loki
and so far as he had basically helped
the asgardians defeat certain he had
saved the universe from destruction
the whole kind of redemption arc had
largely come to fruition in the sense
that kid loki had finally demonstrated
to the asgardians and finally won their
approval in showing hey
i'm not the version of loki that i used
to be the funny thing about this and
this is probably one of the most genius
bits of writing to happen
in the loki series for a long long time
is you ended up learning there were a
few things going on with ikol that you
didn't realize were actually happening
at the time the first of these
is that i cole was just a concept in the
head of kid loki
the second thing is that aikol had
actually been working against kid loki
the entire time
what you got was that following the
events of fear itself you went into a
storyline called the terrorism myth and
this had huge changes for the character
of kid loki so much so that there was
actually a huge amount of fan backlash
to it there wasn't really hatred
it was just people had become attached
to kid loki now in all honesty i thought
it was beautifully handled and i thought
it was beautifully written but the
overall gist of this is that following
fear itself you ended up learning
that the fear people experience right
superheroes super villains regular
humans the fear that people experience
at the hands of the serpent had
basically continued on that it
persisted in their minds in the form of
what were called fear clots right just
these small little nuggets of the
potential fear that the serpent might
return or just kind of holdovers from
everything that had happened this these
kind of fear clots among humanity were
basically seized upon by a villain known
as
nightmare now a lot of you guys have
probably heard of nightmare if only in
passing but the long and short of him is
he basically feeds on people's fears
specifically their nightmares as a way
to kind of bolster himself there have
also been stories where he's put the
whole world to sleep and then fed on the
dream energy from sleeping people and
then bolstered his powers to insane
levels of capabilities but the important
thing here
is that that nightmare had basically led
to the deaths of multiple people by
feeding on their energy and so in order
to save the lives of innocent people
that what kid loki had done is he had
taken the fear of himself at least the
fear of the serpent
all of his insecurities all those things
and condensed them down into a little
source of energy that nightmare could
use and this was all kind of coming into
fruition of something called the fear
crown
and the idea was that nightmare could
utilize the fear crown to amplify his
power
and then in turn conquer all the
different fear dimensions all the other
fearlords and then eventually earth
itself
now during this time what you had was a
character who was a holdover from fear
itself who was named
leah and leah was initially presented
during fear itself and in the aftermath
during the uh the terrorism myth as a
kind of aid to loki i wouldn't really
call her like a sidekick
so much as like a partner in a lot of
ways and in some circumstances she was
almost kind of like the moral voice of
kid loki but regardless the two of them
had basically worked together and then
informed the other fearlords of what it
is that nightmare was doing
which basically led to the fearlords and
nightmare engaging in this kind of
cyclical conflict over trying to attain
the fear crown which kind of removed
them from the picture for the time being
what you ended up getting
in the aftermath of this was the attempt
by the demon mephisto to successfully
grab the fear crown
after defeating all the other fearlords
and then in turn
using it as a means to basically unleash
hell on earth and this is where things
changed for kid loki completely and the
reason for that is up to that point it
seemed like i cole even if he was only
just kind of a potential future version
of himself or
seemingly the the older version of loki
who had returned in his in his physical
form
that instead icole was basically just a
manifestation
of loki in his own mind or at least kid
loki in his own mind that he wasn't
actually real but the overall gist of
this is that
i call represented classic loki and that
personality
and the desire of ikol was to bring
classic loki back but he couldn't do it
through conventional means the only way
to do that was to basically have kid
loki
become classic loki but that wasn't
something kidoki was ready to do
because his entire story up to that
point was a redemption arc he was
looking to become a good guy
as opposed to being viewed as a kind of
villainous character that his former
self had been
and so icole had orchestrated and
manipulated all these different events
ranging from
the idea of building on fear itself for
the purpose of getting kid loki to build
the
fear crown and then giving it to
nightmare knowing that it would be
handed over to mephisto
and then knowing that it would
eventually put kid loki in this position
where the only way to ensure mephisto
could not
seize control of all the hell dimensions
and by extension
everything else across the universe to
basically conquer all of reality was to
destroy the fear crown but because the
fear crown
was really tethered to the mind of of
kid loki
the only way to do that was to eliminate
his existing mind and the only way to
eliminate his existing mind
was to rewrite it so he basically became
his young his former self all over again
albeit in a kid's body and there was a
huge amount of disdain for you know from
kid loki for this perspective because in
his mind he demonstrated the ability to
change that he had become better but he
had to make a choice
was he going to basically let the
universe be conquered by mephisto to
maintain his current
situation or his current uh personality
where he was young he changed he'd
basically been redeemed he was a good
guy now or would he sacrifice all of
that
and destroy mephisto and he chose the
latter he basically allowed his mind to
kind of be rewritten so his former self
could come back in a younger body and
then in turn
mephisto was ultimately defeated but
following this kid loki
largely ended up becoming classic loki
not in the perfect sense it wasn't one
of these things where it was like you
know he's going around and engaging in
all these schemes and and so on and so
forth instead it was a multi-pronged
approach and so by the time he got into
2013 what you actually saw marvel doing
was launching something called marvel
now this was marvel's answer albeit a
poorly planned answer to dc's new 52 and
so marvel now was kind of billed as like
a new jumping on point
it wasn't i would never advise anybody
to start with marvel now largely because
it starts in the middle of nowhere and
so what this did is it kind of
reshuffled things and it actually saw
kid loki
being thrown onto the young avengers
team now this was cool because the young
avengers at the time had a really really
interesting roster
the biggest issue that you had here by
the time you got to 2013
and we talked about this a lot of times
before is that marvel was winding down
right they were getting ready for secret
wars in 2015 and so a lot of these
stories that would have normally seen
huge expansions and a lot of growth
instead
were in a lot of ways stopgap story so
for example during young avengers the
character of wiccan who is destined to
be the demiurge right this being
that could consume and destroy all gods
and possibly even all of reality itself
uh it led to a few stories of loki
involving him and it led to
loki involving the mother and then it
led to all these these weird set of
events and and so on and so forth but
the overall gist of this is that it
focused almost exclusively
on loki's feelings of guilt right the
things that he'd done allowing himself
to become
his former version right allowing
classic loki's personality to more or
less replace his kind of redemption arc
and then in turn going forward from
there and so you learned that like leah
had reappeared but that was just a
manifestation of his guilt that he had
basically left the young avengers
because he didn't believe that he was
worthy
of any of their forgiveness for the
things that he had done it was a lot of
of of just self-deprecation that were
going on in his stories which it wasn't
designed to be like a bad thing it
wasn't designed to be one of these you
know oh woe
is me the world i'm so misunderstood by
the world you know it wasn't really
designed to be like that
it was designed to kind of continue on
focusing on the personality of kid loki
and in a lot of ways the story's kind of
being background which was cool it was a
totally different take on the character
of loki from what we'd ever seen before
and it was great so the the big kicker
about this is that once you get to agent
of asgard
that's really the story that a lot of
people reference as being one of the
best loki runs
in the history of marvel comics and i
agree right because this introduced
future king loki which was kind of like
this
really twisted evil version of the
character that kid loki could become
right that he he would potentially turn
into and that version of loki had done
things like destroy all life on earth he
had become like loki the all butcher
when he took the sword of gor the god
butcher
following gore's death and then
eventually gore returned you saw some
really cool things going on there right
some really really awesome concepts
taking place
but one of the other cool things that
you saw was that he had actually
befriended a woman by the name of
verity willis now verdi willis was cool
because she was a girl that always knew
when she was being lied to
but again stuff was winding down pretty
fast and so what you ended up finding
was a few confrontations with king loki
a lot of the really cool king loki stuff
actually came at the end of agent of
asgard by the time he got around to
issues 14
15 different things like that but you
also kind of got this sort of uh
this is this kind of indication that kid
loki knew a lot more than he was
initially letting on right like when the
multiverse collapsed and the ones who
sat above and shadow had returned there
was a lot of indication that maybe they
were the beyonders but again it was kind
of all over the place right it was sort
of everywhere because in a lot of ways
it was like let's just kind of wrap
these plot threads up let's get into
secret wars and let's just kind of go
from there and so what you really got
here as far as kid loki was concerned
was just the last
days right just the the last days of all
things then you go into the post-secret
wars landscape you basically transition
over to ikol and that's where a bit of
the murkiness comes into play because
it's one of these things where depending
on what comic book fan you're talking to
me for example i consider the whole uh
as guardians of the galaxy storyline to
be the story line where
kid loki stopped being kid loki and
basically became
ikel some people say that it hasn't
really even happened yet right it's one
of these things where it's still
basically kid loki just
operating under a different name or by a
different set of beliefs or whatever the
case happens to be
at this moment right now kid loki in the
traditional sense is not really part of
this anymore
instead it's just ikol who's kind of out
there and there's like king loki in the
future who's his potential future self
there's no guarantee that'll actually
come to fruition but a lot of it just
kind of focuses on him so what we'll do
is we'll make a video on ikol if you
guys are interested in seeing that and
then we'll basically explore
pretty much the concept of loki in the
aftermath of secret wars from 2015 and
how his characters kind of progressed
and grown and gone from there but with
that being said guys thank you all for
watching
and i will catch you all later peace